there's a powerful question of who is
john galt
i don't know if we can do this without
spoilers for the book okay well but you
can say
you can say what what's the importance
of this character what's the importance
of this question i mean without the
so i want to give a talk on who is john
gold and who john galton a sense is
anybody
who takes their own life seriously
anybody who's willing to
really live fully their own life use
their mind in pursuit of
their rational values and pursue their
happiness
fully uncompromisingly with no comp
with no you know compromise and
and you know sticking to the integrity
anybody can be john galton in that sense
i i think one of the mottos i live by
is all you we're tasked to maybe this is
a little bit religious but i think
euron's gonna agree with it i'm sure
you'll agree with it
all any of us can do is leave the world
a little bit of a better place than we
found it
and i think if you do that through hard
work being honest
being a kind uh not at the expense of
other people you can
go to your grave and patting yourself on
the back i mean i mean to me the
the leaving the world a better place
yeah i mean that's that's but that's not
what
drives me what drives me is i mean what
what i think drives people i think
just live a good life and good life
means a life you're happy
living and part of that is the impact
you have on on the world but it's
you know so many people live wasted
lives live mediocre lives leave
conventional lives
you know maybe they even leave the world
a better place but they didn't really
they didn't they didn't leave the world
a better place they left the build a
better place but they didn't
they didn't they didn't um live their
potential
they didn't or they or they died feeling
guilty about it or they
they a million different things so
there's so many productive people i mean
think about all the innovators and the
technologists and the businessmen who
leave the world a better place by a big
shock but are never happy
never happy in their own in their own
souls and known in their own life
and to me that's what counts and if
you're going to be happy you'll leave a
better world of better that's what john
symbolizes to me it's it's living your
life by your standards
by your values and and and pursuing
pursuing that that happens well i think
i'm sorry i take in a different context
because i think a lot of and i don't
think you're going to disagree with this
i think a lot of times when you're young
you have unrealistic expectations what
you're going to accomplish
and you think to yourself well i thought
let's suppose someone wants to go to
politics well if i'm not elected
president i'm a failure
that's nonsensical there's lots of
people who are successful who haven't
achieved literally the top
position their role so if you can go to
your grave
having defending everything you've done
and you've moved the needle
should not be relative yes so that's
back to second-handedness yes
success is not being better than other
people so is not being the best
success is maximizing your potential
whatever that is
and and look you know i know people
you know i have a son who's who could be
a
really good engineer really good
mathematician really good scientist but
he he decided he wants to write comedy
right so
he might have been a better
mathematician than any comedian but
that's his values
that's that's his goals that's what he
wants to do and hopefully he'll be
really really good at that and he'll be
incredibly successful at it
and materially in every other sense but
that's
that's what you pursue you know so it's
it's really
being true to yourself in a deep sense
and
and if you are true to yourself yeah
you'll leave the world a better place
but that's not the essence the essence
is you no
focus on focus on you focus on making
your life the best life that it can be
and if you do that you'll make the world
a better place by
almost by definition but yeah you'll
impact people
we're looking at the same thing in
different ways it's
at least in my little corner of the
world it was disappointing how
rare that that is so one of the reasons
i'm here in austin
and one of the reasons i my work
gravitated
towards elon musk is because he
represents that person for me
in the world of technology in the world
of ceo and the world of business
it was very surprising to me the more
i've learned about the world of
tech how few people live
unapologetically fully to their
potential
i'm sure people others do that maybe
music and art i'm not sure i don't know
about those worlds i do know about the
technology world
and it was disappointing to me how many
people compromise their integrity
in subtle ways at first but then it
becomes a slippery slope and then
i say there's this great quote and i
always forget if it's steinbeck or
hemingway
and the quote and this applies for money
and applies for morality
he the quote was how did you go bankrupt
and he says two ways
gradually and then suddenly it's very
hard
to one day be like i have no integrity
you know that doesn't happen
it's very easy if it's like look i stole
this candy bar
what's the big deal if i steal this
thing then you're still
people say they're no slippy slopes they
are and they're big and they're very
slippery and people just like this is
the biggest one
and and people violate the integrity
even without stealing just little things
about how they treat other people how
they treat themselves
the values they pursued they don't go
after the profession they really wanted
to
they compromise with in ways that they
shouldn't with their spouse or with
their mothers or whatever
they look the other way yep and this is
this is why people go through
uh middle age midlife crisis midlife
crisis is a crisis where you suddenly
realize
i didn't do it i i didn't live up to my
standards i didn't live up to my
youthful idealism i compromised and i
sold out
but i also would warn you about silicon
valley yeah i think
i think at the top very few of them
stick to it and
partially it's the political pressure is
unbearable i mean how would you how
how can you it would require to be a
hero and very few of them are
but there are a lot of people who do
really well at all kinds of levels
in technology who little startups people
and this is the point michael's making
you don't have to be the best
yeah you know you don't have to be a ceo
to uh to lift your max and to live with
integrity and to live a great life
uh i know people who do because they
joined amazon or whatever
have just made a life for themselves an
amazing life for themselves
and have done great work at amazon let's
say
and then have lived a great life because
of the opportunity that
that created for them so i i think
they're more
good people out there but but yes i i
one of the saddest things of growing up
is is noted even when you're when you're
a teenager looking at adults
and noticing how few of them actually
live i mean are really alive
in a sense of living their values and
enjoying their life and
you start with your parents and you look
across the people
everybody lives such mediocre lives yeah
and
the other thing is they don't have to
that's what people don't appreciate it
particularly not in the world that we
live in today they're so wealthy and so
many we all have so many opportunities
right so what
by way of advice what advice would you
give to young people
to live their life fully
i mean michael and i have talked about
this
but it bears repeating so if you look at
john galt if you look at the highest
ideals of what we
of a life we could live what advice
would you give to a 20 year old today 18
year old can i say i don't think
i think and i think rant would agree
when rand was writing john galt
she says when you have this character's
human perfection
you don't want to get too close so he's
a little bit of a vague character
because she was aware that when you're
dealing with day-to-day it kind of the
shine comes off
i think rourke is a lot better character
for a young person
or weirder yeah but but rorke is all the
entirety of foundation that's work so
and we're just one of
them yeah so but rourke is someone where
you could be like okay
and what rourke also gives young people
is that's in the following
the fountainhead is the strength to
persevere
because when you're young you're going
to have down times
there's going to be times when you're
lonely there's going to be times when
you don't have a girlfriend
there's going to be times when you're
out of work and you're thinking
holy crap i'm falling between the cracks
i'm going to accomplish that i'm going
to be a failure
and he gives them the courage to there's
even a scene in the fountain head which
is this amazing scene
i i love that it's not talked about
enough where basically rorke is looking
at one of his buildings and this little
kid on a bicycle comes up to him
and i wrote your own please correct me
and he's like
who built this and works that i did and
the line is
you know rourke didn't realize it but he
just gave that kid the courage to face a
lifetime
and i think that is such a beautiful
thing
where you can find inspiration in this
character don't become needlessly
difficult
don't start parroting his lines you're
not howard rourke and he's not a real
person
but there's aspects of him that you can
apply to your life
and here's something else i'll give one
example because this happened to me when
i was working at goldman sachs i was
doing tech support
and my great-grandmother had passed away
that year and i promised my grandmother
i would have thanks i've told the story
several times
i would have thanksgiving dinner with
her i was working second shift four
to midnight and we were 24 7 help desk
and i got the schedule for the next week
and i i sold my grandma i'm gonna have
lunch with her in thanksgiving and they
had put me down from
four to midnight the day before
wednesday which is my normal shift but
then the day shift the next day
and i go to my boss i go i first of all
second shift i'm like this thanksgiving
i promised my grandma and they're like
well if you could find someone to fill
this
we'll do it and i asked everyone they're
like no and i said i'm not coming in
and i i 100 not even a question if i
asked my grandmother can we have dinner
instead you would have said yes
but this was one of those moments maybe
this is from my huge ego where i felt
like i was in a movie and i'm making a
choice
am i going to ask grandma or
am i going to just bend the knee and i
go i i go i
couldn't find anyone and i go i'm not
coming in and they go if you're not
coming in you're fired
and i go fire me and they did fire me
and i'm gl
and i have no regrets and because if
they if i
if i compromised i'd have money in my
pocket but since i didn't compromise
i could look at that story rand talks
about how man is a being of self-made
soul
i could look at that story and next time
i have a
time where it's a tough decision where
there's really pressure i could be like
you know what
this is the kind of person you are stick
to it i'll give one more example sorry
ron i've given talks on networking and i
tell people
i like to use humor because humor is a
great way to shortcut the brain and get
the truth to them directly
i say if you know someone
is in town with it's their birthday and
they're not doing anything
take them out and i say i do this for
rand reasons i do it selfishly and the
audience laughs
and i go you're laughing but i go the
guy who takes people out for their
birthday is awesome
that could be you there's nothing
stopping you you're just not thinking of
these terms
what's it gonna cost you 30 but for the
rest of their life or a few years
that person will remember you would be
like you know what this person did right
by me
and i'll give you a concrete example
which changed my life profoundly
uh ted hope who was the producer of the
film american splendor which starred my
mentor harvey picard
sent an email to his firm that said
harvey's in town with nothing to do
if you want to hang out with him here's
your chance they worked at a film
company
and i was the only one i got the email i
wasn't working there from a friend
who took him up on it and as a
consequence harvey wrote a graphic novel
about me ego hubris which is 250
on ebay now and it moves at that not too
shabby the point being
you know what someone had a movie made
about him someone is an interesting
figure
take the lunch yeah and stay overtime
for an hour
but so many people don't think in those
terms
and there's so many opportunities for
them and so that's the advice i give and
i think it's also good to give advice
the anecdote so not only is the person
getting the advice
they are learning why you got to that
point and maybe i'm wrong but at least
they've thought about it
yeah i mean i agree with all of that and
i i i like the the line iron man's lying
about man as a self-made soul
is a creature itself my soul is is is
huge and it's something most people
don't realize and it's something that
modern intellectuals undermine
yeah i mean even even somebody like sam
harris when when you keep telling people
they don't have free will
then you don't have a self-made soul
because what is self-made
there is no self according to sam right
he meditates and he sees that he doesn't
have a cell herself
so you're undermining the ability of
people to take control over their own
lives
and make the kind of choices that are
necessary to create the kind of moral
character that is necessary for them to
be successful
so i'd i'd encourage people to go read
found head and atlas shrugged
because put aside the politics put aside
even aspects of the philosophy
focus on these models these are you know
howard walk is a great model for for all
of us it's a great story to have in your
head
in your mind when you encounter
challenging choices
that you might make um and then spend
the time
and this is i you know i don't think i
ever did this when i was young i don't
think people do this but spend the time
thinking about what your values really
are what do you love doing
what what what makes what gets you going
what gets you excited
and and how can i how can i make a
living at this how can i
do this and and live through this and
then
you know think about what kind of life
you want what kind of i don't know what
kind of people you want to hang out with
don't just
don't let life just happen to you
think it through what kind of people for
example if you want ambitious excited
maybe you should move to silicon valley
to austin texas right
um if you want to be around artsy people
you should go to hollywood movies you go
to new york
you know i don't know but but figure out
what kind of life
you want to live what kind of people you
want to hang out what kind of woman
you want to spend your life with what
kind of uh what kind of romantic
relationship you want to have
figure that out and go and do it don't
sit around life is not
or try and fail it's okay you're gonna
fail failure failure
absolutely yeah and and learn from that
failure and that's the other thing think
about what you're doing why you're
succeeding why you're failing
and and keep improving keep working on
it because it's not just going to happen
like this nobody nobody
nobody is francisco to take a character
out of battle shark who succeeds at
everything first try
right we all need to fail a few times we
all need a but
what if you got to lose every second is
never going to be back i mean these are
all cliches but they're all true cliches
right so think make a
cr figure out what your values are and
and
try to apply your your reason your your
rational thought on getting those values
and try to we talked about early on in
the show
in the interview we talked about
integrating your emotions with your
uh cognition i think that's crucial
because you don't want to be fighting
your emotions as you move towards these
things you don't want your emotions to
be barriers
to your own success you want them to be
cheerleaders right to
to to cheer on when good things happen
and and to
to be negative emotions when when it's
justified that they're negative
so work on integrating your soul work so
creating your soul that's that's the
real challenge and i'll give one piece
of meta advice
when you're young you're going to be
clueless because you're going to be
ignorant you know the data
don't ask your dopey friends for advice
because they
want to help parents or but the friends
want to be helpful
they're as dopey as you they have
uninformed as you so they're just going
to give you
platitudes and you're going to be worse
off because now you're going to be
confused
especially with social media reach out
to people who are older than you
who are accomplished you'd be surprised
how often that you got to send them 20
bucks buy them dinner buy their book
whatever it takes you are getting free
world-class advice for very cheap and
and that
is really a mechanism for success and
here's something very unpopular
and not sexy this is why people probably
uh unfollow me that's not why
read well you'll tell me you'll tell me
why i have to read read read
because you're not always gonna have
access to those experts
and i'm not just talking about uh
self-help books i'm not even talking
about self-help
read the words with literature i mean
literature presents you with
all the different characters or you know
read dostoevsky
read read hugo right read all these
authors that have taken time to really
create characters and put them in
situations
that maybe you will never face those
exact situations but you'll face similar
situations
and and they play it out for you you'll
see
what the consequences are great
literature is a real tool
for building your soul great art
generally with literature and
particularly
because it's more conceptual
you